[Laughter]
it is impossible to know just how many
microbial species there are in the world
one recent estimate put the number
somewhere around one trillion species
and the vast majority of those organisms
still have yet to be discovered but even
with our relatively limited knowledge of
the micro cosmos being able to identify
microbes when we can is important from
helping doctors diagnose their patients
to guiding scientists through their
observations
sometimes the goals are a little less
urgent but still meaningful like for
James our master of microscopes who
collects these organisms and tends to
them and for the rest of us on the
journey to the micro cosmos team who
want to share what we've learned we love
showing off these organisms and the more
specific we can get when we identify
them the more we can tell you about
their lives
but even if we humans have only
discovered a small fraction of all the
microbes there's still a lot that we
have found and named so figuring out
what exactly is in our samples can be
difficult it's like playing the board
game guess-who
but first you have to solve a maze to
find it all right board and even when
you do find it you realize you are
playing with the largest guess-who board
ever and still you can't be sure it even
holds the answer as we'll talk about
later scientists have devised a number
of molecular methods that make this task
less daunting but we do things the
old-fashioned way we just look at the
organisms we collect our samples from
nature peering into an assembly of
microscopic animals and single-celled
creatures looking for clues
in their morphology that will hopefully
reveal what they are so come along with
us let's take you through some of the
questions that help guide us through
this process
the best place to start is to ask
yourself in the broadest sense what you
are looking at is it multicellular is it
a unicellular eukaryotes a prokaryote
we'll start with the multicellular
organisms in part because they're
generally a little easier to identify
there are fewer of them in total and
their bodies just have more going on and
that means that there's more clues for
us to find let's take the tardigrade as
an example but pretend that you don't
know what tardigrades look like you went
down to your favorite pond gathered some
water and now you're looking at what you
collected through the microscope on the
other side is this delightful bumbling
bit of life you see some stubby legs
waving around a pair of eyes and maybe
some strange things moving around inside
its body all those details are helpful
legs are a great clue as our eyes and
inside the moving things you're watching
seem a bit like organs if you weren't
sure that you were looking at a
multicellular organism before you
probably are now
and being what you see there's also what
you know you know that you got this
little guy from a pond meaning a
freshwater environment that means you
can rule out organisms that only live in
marine environments so what now you
might be able to get help from a
freshwater biology book but if you're a
hobbyist those books might not be worth
the cost luckily as old-fashioned as our
methodology is we have a resource that
the microbe hunters of your did not the
good ol internet a source not just of
cat pictures and arguments but also of
the many microorganisms that scientists
and science enthusiasts like yourself
have studied and documented sometimes
all you need to do is just a simple
search for something like fresh water
microscopic animal and look through
images until you find something that
matches what you're looking at now of
course fresh water microscopic animal
can bring up a whole range of species
like rotifers hydras and gastro tricks
but each of those animals is very
different from the others which can help
narrow down what your unidentified
microbial organism is and is not if you
find this process overwhelming at first
because you are trying to narrow down
the vastness of the micro cosmos into
just one species that's okay
every time you do this you will get
better at it it takes years of practice
and experience to figure out how to use
all of the information available to you
and pick out the most useful details and
like a baby tardigrade waving its legs
for the first time we all have to start
somewhere
with single-celled eukaryotes the
process starts to get more difficult you
won't see the complex structures and
systems that distinguish multicellular
organisms but you will see organelles
that can help clarify what you're
looking at for example one major clue
can be picking out which organisms have
those beating hairs called cilia versus
which ones have more whip-like hair
called flagella and if you see the green
color of chloroplasts you know that you
need to find an organism capable of
photosynthesis for example what if you
see the tell-tale trumpet morphology in
your collection
AHA you might say that is a Stentor and
you would be correct but which Stentor
whilst enters have varying numbers of
micro nuclei these are hard to see
without staining the macro nucleus
however is visible and can be helpful
for Stentor karolius the macro nucleus
resembles beads strung together across
the cell which is called a Manilla form
nucleus Stentor polymorphous also has a
Manilla form nucleus but it's easier to
distinguish from the Stentor karolius
because of the endosymbiotic algae that
turn it green Stentor igneous by
contrast is smaller and has pink
pigments and contains an oval macro
nucleus stent errs are a relatively
easier genus to pick apart because there
are only about 20 species of centres to
decide between other genera can have
hundreds of species and the differences
might be more subtle that's why
sometimes you'll see our organisms
labeled by the most narrow description
we feel comfortable giving whether
that's identifying an organism solely by
its genus or even going more broad and
just calling it a ciliate these are
cases where we just don't know enough
yet
for those of you who remember our
mystery real-time video it took James a
year to be sure of what organisms
he was watching and until he identified
the mystery organism we didn't know what
was happening in that video and of
course it's even more challenging to
identify bacteria we can use morphology
to parse out cyanobacteria and sulfur
bacteria but with most of the bacteria
and our samples it's just impossible to
tell without genetic sequencing a
technique that is not in our toolkit at
the moment and for us that's okay but
there are cases where it's important to
dig further and scientists have
developed many molecular techniques to
identify the microbes in their samples
there are stains to emphasize certain
identifying structures and biochemical
tests to reveal the presence of specific
enzymes also of course there's gene
sequencing and other more advanced
chemical methods to probe what species a
sample contains for James who does the
work of identifying our microbes without
these molecular tests what he's able to
name comes from years of studying and
memorizing the drawings and pictures
he's found in various books and keys as
well as an ongoing habit of reading
papers every day it's more a way of life
a habit born of science an art a labor
of love
[Music]
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and all these people
on the screen right now these are our
patrons on patreon we only have one
patreon tier it's $8 a month and with it
you get your name featured in the end of
our video here a weekly high-resolution
image of one of our micro friends and an
extended video featuring uncut footage
with no narration from me just Andrew
Wong's wonderful music and if you want
to join up and help us out you can do
that at patreon.com slash journey to
micro if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James check out
Jam and germ on Instagram and if you
want to see more from us just go to
youtube.com slash micro cosmos
[Music]